[Musique]
bonjour vous allez me licencier pas du
tout didier jours vous allez me
licencier onglet dédié
on va à l'essentiel renan parce que
c'est mon coin qui démissionne non je
plaisante et regardez moi s'il vous
plaît j'ai contracté un crédit à la
consommation pour un canapé convertible
ça va c'est pas non plus hyper cher
bonjour vous allez me licencier non
didier on va vous muté juste là à
saint-omer la capelle je peux pas plutôt
que licencier
bonjour
vous allez me licencier je vous avoue
qu' un petit suspense face vous restez
pile vous partez et hop la face on
recommence pourquoi en fait ça les
savoyards et bonjour vous l émission si
vous tombez bien dit oui on va vous
licenciez on veut faire des économies
mais si vous éviter d'imprimer des
portraits des employés de faire du
gâchis de papier et d'encre
on en ferait peut-être des économies
quand c'est vrai ça didier va remplacer
gérard wey gérard vous êtes licencié oui
en fait une petite photo vite fait puis
vous m'appelez le savez non mais c'est
ça qu'il faut pas faire faux pas
imprimer justement mais oui didier vous
met en place et ouais l'avantagé
vous êtes licencié vous avez pas le
pouvoir de faire ça ah bon je suis pas
d'accrocher des portraits au tableau en
vrai si s'ils n'ont pas du tout les
morts ça marche pas c'est pas comme ça
qu'on fait enlever les p'tites vites
bonjour céline licenciés et didier j'en
suis désolé c'est la pire des choses qui
pouvait arriver
thierry je te quitte c'est la pire des
choses qui pouvait m'arriver
monsieur frisottis il met nouvelle
malheureusement votre maman vient de
décéder
c'est vraiment la pire des choses qui
pouvait m'arriver
ça bizarrement ça me dérange pas plus
que ça
[Musique]
vous allez me sens si oui mais je
travaille même pas ici on vous embauche
au cool et maintenant vous licencie pas
son fort enfant on avait commandé une
pizza non bonjour vous allez me
licencier et oui dédié enfin le licencié
parce que c'est pas mal hein si si non
non oh que si elles sont une fois le
temps ce bonjour vous allez me licencier
je vous préviens si vous me sens et je
dis à tout le monde que vous êtes
ensemble à toute la boîte gens les
anniversaires
[Musique]
par bonheur a sonné pour le trot pour
l'autre
pour